mr lansky
is this such a thing as organized crime
i have no knowledge on the subject
it's alaska it's a pleasure why does
david still want to write a book about
me
maybe i like stories about complicated
people
anything i choose to tell you is off the
record until i give you permission to
put it in the book
any conversations you have about me i
want to know
betray me and there will be consequences
i don't have the power to change my past
i do have the power to change the
perception of it
i built my business from the ground up
you don't choose sides
you choose opportunities make him feel
it benny
no they still consider you part of the
underworld
we were the underworld we were the
overworld
lansky has 300 million dollars
squirreled away and we want your help
finding it
now we could let it slip to mr lansky
that you've been sharing his secrets
that's not gonna go well for you
there are people in this world who will
try to make you believe that they are
better than you
rage is a tool we use to prove them
wrong
i don't question the choices i make
[Music]
we've got a paper trail of laundry money
going in and out of geneva
lose your character you lose everything
remember that
never let your emotions dictate you
i'm an angel with a dirty face
say what you tell yourself you can't
sleep at night i don't have to tell
myself anything but i go to sleep at
night
it's the way we live it's business
you